ma touche à X 28 directeur de l'iglou
chaudron on a ouvert notre entreprise il
y a 2 ans et demi maintenant on propose
essentiellement des glaces des repas
chauds des repas B froid on va dire des
assiettes de crêpe et on se on est sur
le point de proposer une carte de
samousa de sandwich restaurant on
accueille environ 80 personnes assises
on fait également de la vente à
l'emporté c'est-à-dire glace vacherin
bûche pour les périodes de fête nous
sommes actuellement deux salariés et moi
et ma femme 4 on travaille dans dans une
ambiance plutôt bon enfant avec le
sourire
et les amis viennent la famille tout le
monde est les bienvenu en fait on est
constamment en recherche de de personnel
de que ça soit en employé polyvalent en
extra ou en contrat à temps
plein on recherche souvent du personnel
et on en général on se base plutôt sur
des jeunes filles euh polyvalente avec
une un minimum de dextérité aucune
aucune expérience requise on va dire vu
que on apprend tout sur sur le tas et si
expérience il y a ça nous dérangerait
pas les mission à accomplir sont ceux
d'une serveuse on va dire d'une serveuse
de de partout c'est-à-dire l'entretien
des locaux le service des glaces
l'accueil des clientèles la caisse
et voilà le post pour avoir à partir de
2015 un CDD avec un contrat d'avenir si
si dem
a le serveur ou la serveuse doit prendre
en charge la mise en place des tables
gérer l'accueil des clients et
l'encaissement être capable d'assurer le
service faire preuve de
polyvalence le que je peux donner aux
futurs candidats qui vont venir ici
c'est d'avoir déjà une très bonne
présentation une
élocution une bonne éloction français et
également arriver avec minimum 5 minutes
d'avance ça c'est une preuve de de
ponctualité bonjour je m'appelle NAA fet
j'ai 24 ans habite à Saint-Denis et je
recherche un emploi dans le domaine de
la culture ou de la communication j'ai
un
baccalauréat technologique en
communication ensuite j'ai enchaîné par
un BTS Tourisme et ensuite j'ai fait une
licence en Information et Communication
à l'Université de la Réunion et après
j'ai terminé par un master en
anthropologie des société de l'océan
Indien je recherche comme type de poste
alors le poste d'assistante en
communication et dans le domaine de la
culture ce serait plus comme en tant que
chef de projet culturel j'aimerais
travailler en fait dans le secteur nord
dans la zone Nord où j'habite mais ça me
poserait pas de problème de travailler
dans la zone ouest et dans la zone sud
je suis une personne volontaire
rigoureuse consciencieuse j'essaie de
faire le mieux en fait dans les tâches
que que je fais par exemple pour mon
Master j'ai mis du cœur à faire mon
mémoire et j'aime rendre un travail bien
fait on va dire je suis prête en fait à
arriver un poste et où je pourrais
apporter mes compétences les qualités
que j'ai que j'ai et tout mon
savoir-faire que j'ai pu avoir durant
les formations que j'ai pu effectuer que
ce soit à la Réunion ou en métropole je
sais très bien que quand on entre dans
une entreprise AA peut-être commencer au
bas de l'échelle et ensuite pouvoir
évoluer comme tout le monde
contactez-nous sur notre page Facebook
www.facebook.com/974tv ou par téléphone
0262 92
974 CV votre émission au service de
l'emploi à la
Réunion